with FIFA 15 we've created the game that
lets you feel the emotion of football
like never before you will feel the game
emotion touches everything we're showing
you today incredible visuals that blur
the line between the virtual in the real
world and emotional intelligence that
connects every player on the pitch
players now have memories that will show
their emotion based on the context of
the match from the ecstasy of triumph to
the agony of defeat it's a level of
creative expression as a game developer
we've only ever dreamed of but now it's
alive in FIFA 15 our player control
system brings an all new level of player
personality and responsiveness to the
game new stuffers and strides let you
cut sprint and explode out of turns and
on your ball physics system models
movement depending on precise contacts
with the ball it's creating
astonishingly realistic trajectories and
spin you'll feel the physicality of the
sport in man-to-man battles full-body
defending shirts pulling shoulder barges
and possession tackles fundamentally
changed the way you compete for the ball
and we have created the next generation
football player athletic lean and
stunningly realistic you'll not only
feel their athleticism you'll see it too
FIFA 15 will have atmosphere that you
can feel the pulse now at Etihad Stadium
the frenetic energy at La Bombonera the
[ __ ] am filled feel immersed in these
iconic theatres of sport witness the
sights and sounds that make you feel
just like you're there on the pitch
boots will leave their mark hard slide
tackles will tear the turf and kits will
get dirty add boards animates corner
flags will move and gold frames clatter
on impact the entire stadium is alive
and packed with
motion all of this adds up to a fever
experience where you'll feel the emotion
intensity and athleticism of football
there's much more news to come before we
launch this fall this year you will feel
the game